[Musique]
ce vendredi 8 septembre Cyril Melchior
président du département et André
tienacun mère du tampon posait la
première pierre d'une vaste retenue
colinaire qui sera construite à la
Plaine des Cafres
ces travaux consistent donc en la
réalisation d'un bassin de retenue d'eau
qui permettra de stocker 350 000 mètres
cubes d'eau
et ensuite comme ça a été dit dans les
différents discours qui permettra en
fait d'approvisionner les terrains
agricoles
en eau brut c'est à dire non potabilisé
gestionnaire tu fais adhère le
département apporte les 20 millions
d'euros nécessaires à la construction de
cet équipement
quand il s'agit
d'adduction d'eau le département et le
pilote
depuis 30 ans
le Conseil départemental
apporter tous les projets réunis
ambassade d'infrastructure en eau l'eau
c'est la vie et on a été chercher l'eau
depuis
Salazie pour l'emmener jusqu'à
Saint-Paul et ensuite la distribuer dans
toute la zone ouest de Lille avec une
connexion avec la zone sud aujourd'hui
des milliers d'hectares sont irrigués
grâce à le capter par le Conseil
départemental mais nos efforts se
complètent à travers les retenues
colinéaires et le département accompagne
les agriculteurs dans la réalisation de
retenue colinéaire individuelle chez
l'agriculteur
et puis il y a le choix des grandes
retenues que porte la commune du Tampon
s'est retenu par exemple aujourd'hui à
travers la pose de leur première pierre
d'une retenue de 350 000 mètres cubes
d'eau et bien grâce à cette retenue
colinéaire collective près de 200
hectares seront irrigués la commune du
Tampon est le grenier agricole de Lille
le maire souhaite donner aux
agriculteurs tous les moyens pour
réussir
à 1700 mètres d'altitude constitue une
performance exceptionnelle et c'est la
troisième que nous avons construit
depuis la première la seconde et la
troisième et nous avons organisé 4
autres ils ont mettre derrière ces
retenues colinéaires des
usines hydroélectriques qui permettront
de donner de l'énergie donc à la
population réunionnaise parce que c'est
la priorité gouvernementale aujourd'hui
de réaliser de tels équipements
développement durable sauvé reconnaître
sauvé des horticulteurs sur une autre
population les travaux de cette retenue
colinéaire devraient durer 18 mois
[Musique]